Emerson on mangog was inauguration
ceremony went off with a bang and a
massive military salute his fearsome
reputation earned him the nickname of
the crocodile and after he was sacked a
month ago by outdid President Robert
Mugabe he has snapped back to take power
his inauguration comes after the sudden
end to maga Bay's 37 year rule that he
paid tribute to the man he replaces his
support is not so surprising four years
of mangaka was Akiba gob a ally helping
direct Zimbabwe swore of independence in
the 1970s in the 80s he became a feared
spy master during his years of civil
conflict he saw himself as successor to
his aging mentor but fell out with maga
bay when it became clear he wanted to
install his wife grace as president
instead despite the obvious support not
everyone's convinced that things will be
so different superficially changes come
but what can we expect from them you
know I'm really asking myself after
working together for the past 37 years
what's changed can they bring will our
people be happy or will our expectations
be delivered under this new dispensation
there's certainly a lot to do
Zimbabwe sural economy has been wrecked
by Robert Mugabe's decades long drive to
confiscate white owned farms business
leaders hope boom nan guar can use his
international connections to revitalize
activity the crocodile is promising
Zimbabwe as a new era of democracy hopes
may be high but there are also doubts
about what lies ahead
you